we're human beings with the blood of a
million
savage years on our hands
but we can stop it we can admit that
we're
killers but we're not going to kill
today that's all it takes
that we're not going to kill today
hey guys pete here it's time for my for
all mankind season 2 episode 9 breakdown
it's a pretty straightforward setup and
race to the end episode with just a few
side character plots to tie
up the penultimate episode had a
surprising ending though
i didn't see coming i have to say not
how it played out anyway
before we get into that this is your
spoiler warning make sure you go and
watch the episode before you watch this
video or you will be spoiled
please do subscribe on your way out
though so you won't get lost on your way
back
with that out of the way let's get to it
things start off right after the killing
of the soviet cosmonaut at the end of
episode 8. the second cosmonaut who was
shot was rushed to jamestown base where
the doctor is doing her best to try to
save him
he won't end up dying but he does remain
unconscious for most of the episode
when asked the moon marines say they
perceived a hostile intent
but are forced to admit that they found
no weapons in the case
or anywhere else for that matter on
earth ellen margot and bradford are
assessing the situation
knowing full well that wars have been
started over less
bradford makes it plain that if this
turns into world war 3
the 20 million that were killed back in
the first world war that's gonna seem
like a car accident in comparison
as you would imagine the soviet
leadership is outraged about the
situation on the moon
and they're out there making statements
saying that they have intelligence that
sea dragon 17 will be carrying nukes to
the moon
we'll learn that they've launched their
bronze shuttle and bradford tells us
that the cia says that it's armed to the
teeth
at jsc they watch baron dock with the
soviet space station
they see that it refuels there and then
it burns towards the moon
apparently based on what ellen says here
this is how the us
does it with their shuttles so that they
can make lunar orbit as well
this has been a thing that i've seen in
the comments over and over again
people complaining about the fact that
they're using shuttles and that the
shuttle could never make it to the moon
i guess this is your explanation for
that it looks like the plan is to use
the armed
bronze shuttle to blockade the moon so
that the next sea dragon flight can't
make it there
this leads to molly calling ed into her
office
and letting him know that the dod is
officially taking over the pathfinder
mission
the plan is for the armed pathfinder to
escort sea dragon
in a move to prevent any aggression from
the soviets armed shuttle
as ed's telling his crew sally ride
pretty much calls it for what it is
it's basically a game of chicken because
if the baron would have gotten to the
point of firing then the pathfinder's
mission would be a failure
they're betting that if they show up
with weapons then the soviets will have
to back down from using theirs
because blowing up the sea dragon would
mean that their shuttle would be
destroyed by
pathfinder and pathfinder as piscotty
says
has a longer range with its missiles so
they're just hoping that that will be
enough
ed does give both members of his crew
the option of resigning if they're not
okay with it but neither of them take
him up on the offer
from a news report we see that the
soviets have moved their northern
fleet it's now headed toward the panama
canal
and in response the us has set the
threat level to defcon
3. ed comes home to tell the family that
the launch date for pathfinder got moved
up
and kelly is worried karen steps in and
won't let ed reassure her she says that
he can't promise that things will be all
right
which is true and he concedes that but
tries to make her feel better about the
situation
after he says goodbye to kelly he asks
karen to walk into the car
and ask her if she's all right he knows
something's up and he doesn't want to
leave without her telling him what's
going on
she tries to put it off saying that they
can talk when he gets back but he
insists
so she eventually tells him that she
slept with someone
it's a gut punch he didn't see it coming
she makes the point of saying it was the
decision that she made she wasn't drunk
or anything like that
and then tries to play it down saying it
was a one-time thing
and it doesn't matter his blood is up
though he can't make sense of what's
happening
he wants to know who it was she won't
say and it all ends with him storming
off but we know that they're going to
come back to it at some point
the basic takeaway is that karen isn't
sure if she still wants to be married to
ed she'd like to get counseling now that
this has happened
and he's got an important mission that
he's getting ready to go on
so it's a pretty bad situation all the
way across the board
later we'll see him drinking at a bar
ruminating
looking at his wedding ring there's a
woman across the bar
looking his way they share a smile they
end up back in his room going at it
when the time comes he can't perform and
even though she's very
encouraging he ends up not going through
with it
so sea dragon 17 does launch that means
pathfinder's ready to go
but ed's head is elsewhere we see that
he's thinking about his fight with karen
and at one point totally misses what
piscotty's telling him
it's interesting because we see at jsc
that they're monitoring the sea dragon
launch but not
pathfinder since the dod took control of
that mission
pathfinder does a striking air launch to
orbit and the reveal shot is great
ed says are you all ready for the
inaugural flight of the most badass
nuclear rocket to ever grace god's green
earth
then we get that roll of the camera from
where they
looked like they were sitting on the
launch pad and then we see it pull out
to see that it is riding on the back of
a shuttle carrier aircraft
we see them engage the nerva engine and
then have an
intense if not long transition from
earth's atmosphere
ed talks about flying into space not
launching or blasting off
and the sea dragon pathfinder rendezvous
is on
back on the moon we'd seen a message
saying that the soviets were
sending people over with the intention
of retrieving their two cosmonauts
and eventually two soviet cosmonauts
arrive at jamestown
there's a lot of posturing when they get
there they both want to go
inside but only the doctor is allowed to
see the injured cosmonaut
when webster tries to talk to him
explain what happened
he says that she should be tried for
crimes in an international court
he wants to take the injured cosmonaut
back to their base but
the people of jamestown won't let him
because it will probably
kill him it seems like he doesn't want
him to wake up with only nasa
people around tensions are high there's
security risks to think about
eventually they show them the burnt
cosmonaut which is gruesome
it's a hard situation for them seeing
their comrade
killed that way seeing his dead body the
commander of jamestown says that they
think that the bullet made a spark and
the pure oxygen ignited inside the suit
and like i said this is an emotional
situation for the soviets
when nasa offers to help them move the
body the cosmonaut loses it a bit and
says you will not touch his body
and you kind of see where he's coming
from here later we do
see that the other cosmonaut wakes up
and when he realizes he's in the
american base
he announces that he wishes to defect to
the united states he asked for amnesty
basically
on earth we see ellen say that they're
going to allow him to do that and this
means there's another complicated
situation brewing up there so margot
asked about apollo soyuz at first
ellen says that if the president would
ask her she was gonna tell him not to go
through with it
margot has a better idea though she
encourages her to wait and see
because if the soviets launch soyuz
then they'll have a better idea about
what's going on
and that all makes sense so they decide
to go with that plan
we see danny and her crewmate getting
ready for launch
she forgot to take off her ring so
there's an emotional moment there when
she's thinking about clayton
later we see them sitting on the launch
pad waiting to see if soyuz will go so
they can find out if their mission is on
as they're waiting danny says we're
human beings with the blood of a million
savage years on our hands but we can
stop it we can admit that we're killers
but we're
not gonna kill today that's all it takes
knowing that we won't kill today that's
from star trek
season 1 episode 23 as she says and it
makes for a pretty powerful moment
at mission control we see sergey contact
margot and tell her that soyuz has
launched and that their cosmonauts look
forward to meeting the apollo astronauts
in space
then we get to see the apollo launch and
so far
so good apollo soyuz is still moving
ahead
even though pathfinder is currently on
its way to go
confront burron and try to break this
blockade
so i will circle around to talk about
everything that's set up in space for
the finale
after i talk about the ending but as i
said at the beginning there are a few
side character story beats that we need
to talk about
as well the first one is molly and wayne
we learned in the last episode that
molly was on her way to being blind
and here we see that she's trying to set
up something
where she can beat that and that has led
her to the point of wanting to go down
to mexico and get an experimental
treatment that doesn't sound all
that good wayne realizes this and he
tries to talk her out of it
eventually she's on her way to take off
and she's basically not telling him
what's going on
he calls her out he knows that she took
ten thousand dollars out of their bank
account
and he threatens her he says look if you
go do this then i'm not going to be here
when you come back
and in a rage she storms out planning to
go through with it anyways
we see that she almost makes it to a
plane to fly away
but then stops and changes her mind when
she returns home we see that wayne was
following through with this promise he's
packing up his stuff he's getting ready
to go
but he's not gone yet and they have a
heartfelt reunion
and yeah she's probably gonna end up
blind but she made the right decision
also there was a scene with lee atwater
showing up to talk to larry at ellen and
larry's place
trying to get him to push ellen into
running for office starting a political
career
he makes a good case for it and you
could see that she probably does have
potential in that area and then we see
pam come
in and she hears what they're talking
about and that makes her really start to
question what she should do
later we see ellen come home where she
finds a letter
in that pam lies she says that she just
wants to go back to elise
trying to let her off the hook easy and
this is devastating for ellen
and it's kind of a sad ending for the
two
maybe it's not the ending ending but for
right now
because basically pam is just stepping
aside so ellen can have her career
because of the social norms being the
way they are they can't be together
publicly and have her still hold on to
that position
also we saw tracy and gordo have a
moment early in the episode
later when she's going to smoke we see
that he's waiting there to surprise her
and he makes his move she plays with
them a bit and at the end they head into
the smoking room
with the implication that they're gonna
hook up but perhaps more importantly
what they
are right now is they're isolated from
the rest of the people on
jamestown because over at the command
center we see a crew there doing their
tests
and they notice that there's a cosmonaut
standing outside the window
he pulls out a gun he shoots it at the
window
that causes a loss of pressure most of
them are able to get
out of that section and close the door
but one of them does get sucked out into
the vacuum
and the episode ends with an armed
cosmonaut
entering the base and we see that the
commander is in his office he sealed off
in an
airtight room so he's with them gordo
and tracy
are alone in that section where she
smokes
and i was pretty surprised at this and
i'm really not sure a hundred percent
what is going on like obviously they
attacked jamestown base
but did they do that on their own
because of what happened when they saw
their fallen comrade earlier
we saw that that one cosmonaut was
really upset
so there's a very distinct possibility
that he went back
and he told the other guys what he saw
what happened they found out that the
other cosmonaut wanted to defect maybe
they believed that maybe they didn't
and i think there's a real possibility
that they're just acting on their own
here we'll have to wait until next week
to find out
but if you think about it the whole
point of margot telling ellen to wait
and see on apollo soyuz
was that they thought that if they
launched soyuz then that would be the
indication that they were ready to
de-escalate
so them launching that doesn't really
seem to jive with
launching a ground offensive to take
jamestown base
forcefully but like i said we'll have to
wait and see
so it was an intense episode it's set up
for a crazy looking finale
there was definitely some drama but
everything seemed pretty balanced out
gordo and tracy being off by themselves
coming back together
starting to look like things are working
out does make me worry about their
futures which i've talked about in the
last couple of videos
the conclusion to pam and ellen's
romance was somewhat disappointing
though i was happy to see that wayne was
able to get through to molly
even though that's a little bittersweet
considering that her career
as a pilot is over i was blown away by
the pathfinder launch and the way they
presented that i thought that worked out
really well
the nerva engine was a nice touch and
it's nice to see that that program
is still ongoing considering it was
cancelled in our timeline
when they pulled back from space
exploration in general
there are actually quite a few cool
looking launches in this episode
and we have a pissed off ed heading
towards an armed baron shuttle
with the armed pathfinder karen's
indiscretions do
serve to make this more volatile but i
mean
making danny the choice for that is
still pretty inexplicable at this point
we'll have to see where that goes
apollo and soyuz are both up there as
far as we know
and there was an image of them in orbit
on the watch page on apple tv
hard to say how that'll play out now
that things are escalating on the
surface
but it is a nice setup and i can't wait
to see how they resolve things in the
finale
the defection and the fallout from that
was actually surprising
i expected things to get intense but i
hadn't expected that we would see a
strike team waltzing through the window
at jamestown there is a lot to talk
about but i think this is a good place
to leave the video
so let me know in the comments where you
think things are heading
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon